hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in chapter 6 of
book two of Aristotle's Nicomachean
ethics he makes a very important
qualification particularly for those who
get a little mixed up about the nature
of virtue ethics and imagine that virtue
ethics is merely about finding a mean in
whatever sort of thing we're talking
about that as a middle position and it
automatically says that because you
found the middle position and after
you've hit the virtue and that's there
for good and so you would in excess and
deficiency Aristotle says that there are
some things some actions and some
emotions that by their very nature are
bad that they are morally defective you
could say there is no way of taking them
as such and making them into something
good so the way that he talks about it
is very interesting he says that some
emotions and some actions do not admit
of any sort virtuous mean and we'll look
at which ones he's talking about first
he says that the very names of some of
them imply evil or deficiency or bad
in some in some sense and I think that
that holds for our own moral vocabulary
as well the question that is of course
whether be whether we rightly classify
an action as belonging to that that
class of morally deficient actions how
we rightly apply the the names and
concepts without that's for a different
time let's see what else he says he said
well you know with any of these things
it's not possible to go right with
regard to them so let's take one of the
examples that he uses adultery you know
he says is it possible to commit
adultery with the right woman in this
case or right man at the right time in
the right manner and aerosol says no
because it's adulterer in here if you're
violating the fidelity of the marriage
bond that's a problem no matter how are
you qualify it and this is interesting
because this is one of those things
where Aristotle is not going to let
somebody off by saying well you know I I
don't do it all the time this is just
this one time that I'm doing this
ourselves even one times bad you
shouldn't do it well I'm doing it
because my spouse doesn't give me what I
need or because that person is so lonely
and I just want to comfort them no don't
do it bad idea it's a bad thing no
matter how you pitch it no matter how
are you you know twist your perspective
so that you can try and see it is good
there is no possibility of construing it
as a virtuous action the weather we
talked about it in terms of a action
showing virtue or inaction in accordance
with virtue we have another video on
that he goes on Elise's you might as
well suppose there could be a proper
mean and excess and deficiency and acts
of injustice or cowardice or prolificacy
I know for example think about a bribery
and the way that some people think about
bribes you know
by its very nature bribery there's
something wrong with it yeah that's
revealed in the very name Aristotle
would say now can you bribe somebody too
much enough it's still bribery no matter
what you do and similarly with all of
these these other things as well so
let's let's take a look at them we let's
take a look at the actions first so
adultery we already talked about that
some sort of violation of fidelity
interestingly and notice that nearly
every moral code around the world
defined sexuality in some way that
includes some sort of offense against a
committed relationship most cultures at
least at least all the ones we know
about theft another one that you're not
supposed to engage in clopay in Greek
taking other people's things without
their permission there's a whole bunch
of other things that could count as
theft as well and typically we look at
theft as being an offense against
justice as perhaps adultery is as well
murder here the return for that is I'm
going to phony up killing a person
merino murder now you can say well wait
a second what about you know battlefield
courage you're going out there and
you're jabbing somebody else with your
steer or your sword or swinging in the
axe at them well there's a different
description of that act you're not just
simply wandering around looking for
people to kill there were examples some
people who live in that back that and
today and you know you could also do
andhra fonia in the way that we took my
mam's water body by being stupid or
being inattentive and doing things that
put other people at risk there is no
good way to spend these there is no
right amount of these it's not like you
can say well look I only killed three
people that's not that big of a deal
because serial killers tend to kill more
not only you're killing people so you're
famous stealing this is adjusting
people often yet I'm just having a
little taste I'm not really stealing I'm
just you know skimming a little bit no
you're you're stealing and we can go on
and on with that another really
interesting aspect of this is when it
comes to emotions Aristotle thinks that
there are certain emotional states that
simply are not good and that cannot be
somehow redeemed made good they may be
brought into sort of a situation where
societally we could use them to get
certain things done that might conduce
to some good but in the person
themselves they're a bad thing and it
doesn't matter in certain respects how
much of it you have or who you feel it
towards it's a bad thing it's a worse
thing of course if you have more of it
so the first one that he talks about and
they hear this when he talks about being
revealed in the very name this is a
great example epi hired a cocky
literally means setting your hands to
wickedness setting your hands to badness
or setting your hands device because
kochia also means a vice when we talk
about somebody being malicious in terms
of their emotions we mean that they have
a motivation of doing bad things or
harming people just for the sake of
doing not even necessarily to get
anything tangible out of it just to do
it to do it shamelessness another
example lacking in shame or laughing and
modesty we're going to talk about this
in another core concept video these
Kwazii virtue of shame laughing shame
whatsoever just doing whatever like
walking around for example in our
society with your finger up your nose
digging away would be an example of
shamelessness when we talk about
somebody being a shameless self-promoter
you know being very slick and coming in
and always trying to turn everything
into a business opportunity that would
be an example of shame
lessness as well perhaps when it comes
to like sexual relations we might in our
culture all the way our subbable didn't
talk about that talk about certain kind
of shamelessness as for example when
sexual partners make demands upon each
other then really go beyond the bounds
and are coming out of left field and
you're like we want me to do what and
they don't seem to have any sort of
problem or embarrassment about it
perhaps that's what Aristotle stocking
by the shamelessness as well and now
notice the last one and thaw knows this
is never good according to Aristotle
there is no way to make Envy into
something good and he is aroused at the
sight of goods that somebody else enjoys
but instead of being happy that they
enjoy them you feel pain because they're
not yours and Aristotle thinks that this
is something fundamentally bad so this
is a sort of list of exceptions to the
whole notion of the virtuous mean not
because you know Aristotle suddenly
veers laughing today ontology or some
other kind of ethics but just because
look these don't have a virtuous mean to
them so there's no way to somehow we've
avert you out of any of these